mobile podcast and video Studio buy like
a few Vans get them out with like a
pretty fire setup just in the back of
like a normal size van doesn't even have
to be an RV for like two to three people
could fit deck it out with like a few
good DSLR cameras that can do the
recording like dual camera setups that
you have like a few mics hanging off the
sides and basically go and post it up in
a couple of major cities like one band
in each major city and rent it out for
like 500 bucks for two hours to do
podcast recordings or like you know a
couple hundred bucks to do like people
going in and filming Instagram shorts
tick tocks [__] like that like if you
put one in LA and you put one in New
York City I bet you could kill it
[Music]
foreign
the man who answers the question what
would happen if Sean was better looking
smarter harder working so Bloom is
smarter
[Laughter]
with you so what's up guys happy to be
here how often do you get your hair cut
let's start with the most important
question uh you know like every other
week at this point now my wife is making
fun of me for this because like it used
to be that I'd go once a month wasn't a
big deal and now I'm going like every
other week because I like to keep it
tight and she keeps giving me [__]
because we have a little newborn at home
and I'm like oh I gotta go Gotta Go
um so yeah it's becoming an issue you
don't call it a hair appointment that's
the only thing you can't do if you say I
got a hair appointment then you're out
as a guy the police just can't be called
a salon that's always been my rule it's
an easy Barber Shop you seem like you
seem like a salon guy though man you're
wearing like a you got like a Werther
sweater on you look like you're getting
ready for Christmas it's like it's 85
degrees in Austin Texas today yeah so
are we at your like book reading for
your for your book right now Sam what
are you doing it actually does look like
you should have a fireplace in the
background and you're gonna be like
reading us nice stories and a soothing
voice I'm definitely drinking tea right
now uh so basically like your bio is
pretty easy you were a nobody private
Equity guy the pandemic hit the pandemic
hit and you're like I'm gonna be
somebody in a matter of two years you've
got famous on Twitter what do we what do
we have nine or eight hundred thousand
followers so you got famous on Twitter
and basically transformed your life all
because of Twitter and covid is that
right I mean the nobody private Equity
guide designation is not unreasonable I
mean that's like I think that's totally
fair I mean there's a lot of nobody like
Finance guys that are making bank out
there though right like that was uh that
would have stung but now you're like
famous and stuff so now it's okay to
laugh at it I mean I don't know like do
you think it's things like the if you're
making pretty good money doing something
like that I mean VPS and private Equity
at this point if you're doing well like
you're making seven figures as a BP in
private equity name four of them yeah
what about dude I hung out with some PE
guys the other day and I didn't know
them well enough but obviously I just in
the back of my head how rich are you and
that's like just what I wanted to keep
asking are if you own a PE shop is it
safe to assume that you're just wealthy
and how much do they actually earn yeah
I mean if you are if you are a GP so
like one of the principal owners of a
private Equity Fund and you've been
doing it like across multiple funds that
have performed well over a period of
time it's pretty safe to assume that
you've got a net worth north of 50
million dollars because I mean you just
like simple math on it right most of
those funds are taking like one and a
half to two percent management fees on
you know if you're running a big fund
500 million plus a billion plus if it's
like a real substantial fund so there's
you know 20 million plus coming in a
year on a billion dollar fund uh and
realistically most of them don't have
that many employees so they're not
having to actually pay out a ton of that
in terms of like you know operating
costs and then you have Carrie and
they're taking you know 15 20 25 percent
uh of profits above their hurdle rate
whatever that is eight percent so you're
like you know you're talking about if
they double the funds there's 200
million dollars plus of carry to go
around and so the principal owners of
those are taking the Lion's Share of
that which is
I mean if there's 200 million in their
principal owner owns 20 30 of that it's
a [__] ton of money and the I think that
I've always I can't decide if it's
jealousy because I'm like you guys are
making a lot of money for what feels
like not a lot of work or if it's
actually I dislike them because I feel
as though they're just like Excel sheet
monkeys and they're like not actually
creating value what where's the reality
no I mean they work crazy hard man I I
don't um I don't know anyone that is a
long time GP uh in private Equity that
doesn't work you know 70 plus hours a
week of like stressful work I mean it's
the type of thing Sean would absolutely
hate like you think about like people
that care about leverage on their time
it's like pretty piss-poor leverage and
it's high stress work because you're
putting much a debt on these companies
typically and you know during a downturn
like right now right it's hugely
stressful because you're constantly
dealing with like breaking covenants on
the debt and having to restructure and
you know like basically what ends up
happening is you spend 80 of your time
on the like couple of losers in the
portfolio and the winners you just like
kind of get to set and forget it because
they're growing they're you know you're
getting like a levered upside on them
because you put you know 70 leverage to
buy the company 60 leverage to buy the
company and you're just like eating off
those couple of winners but you're
dealing constantly with the ones that
are losers so Sean and I have our hand
in this world where like we've
definitely sell and have sold courses
and information stuff we also have a
podcast and so that that's like this
like personality world but then we also
have built uh nice size companies and we
will continue to build very likely much
bigger companies and so we have our foot
in that world for you you have your foot
in like the PE world as well as the
thing that we're in this information
thing where do you think do you think
that one do you think that the
information world or whatever we call
this thing is actually a uh is it an
equal uh revenue or net worth driver as
like some of the traditional company
building or PE stuff
yeah I mean like I think
you have to think about it in terms of
like your uh you know profit potential
multiplied by like the freedom and time
Freedom that comes with it right to like
get to like kind of an adjusted profit
that you can generate from something
doing it in PE and like making 50
million dollars in PE from a time
adjusted standpoint is a is a pretty
grindy way to go do it it's like high
certainty if you're just on if you're at
a good fund and you're rolling with a
good fund and you're like gonna be a
partner there and you're going to get
more and more carry across you know
bigger and bigger funds it's a pretty
low beta way to go and generate that
type of you know that type of net worth
but you're going to be working your ass
off until you're like 60 years old doing
it versus you know you go on the
information side uh into the information
economy and you're like doing newsletter
doing podcast courses stuff that you
guys are doing where you're like you
know Sean might do his course and in a
week make 300K uh and then be able to
chill for you know two three months if
he wants to because who cares right it's
like it's just a totally different time
leverage
um so I don't know it's sort of depends
on like what you want to do in that
regard dude what's your what's your job
now I mean I kind of do like 10
different things
um I've got the fund you know like so I
ended up raising the fun I didn't do the
rolling fundex Sean but I've got a 10
million dollar Venture fund that I
raised from you know a handful of
Institutions and then a bunch of like
the GPS at Big funds invested in it and
basically like kind of share deal flow
um I've got the newsletter which you
know monetizes it's like but we could
talk about it but like you know with
newsletter sponsors now it's 125-ish
thousand subs and you know it makes
anywhere from like three and a half to
six thousand dollars per cent right now
and I send it you know eight to ten
times a month so
um you know pretty nice just like
business that scales to your point on
like time leverage I write the same two
newsletters a week and it's pretty nice
business and then I had this agency
business that frankly like
started just because it was like
something that I saw you know as an
Arbitrage opportunity early in like 2021
and it ended up scaling into like you
know order magnitude probably like close
to six figures a month
um gross revenue business with super
high margins and so I kind of just like
kept doing it and kept walking into
different areas with it
and I don't know if you guys talked
about this already but you had come to
us or you were kind of talking on our
group chat about like
the fork in the road moment you had you
were like we said before no name private
Equity guy uh making good money and you
had started tweeting out stuff like
pretty regularly I would say I don't
know six months or a year before that
um and you it was clear you had momentum
it was clear you were good at that uh
you were getting followers maybe had 100
000 or 200 000 followers maybe at that
time I'm just rounding around and uh but
it wasn't you didn't have all these
other things like this clear like I have
a fund I have a newsletter that makes
money I have an agency that makes money
so you didn't know exactly what was on
the other side of that Hill as you were
debating what should I do should I you
know the forking through a lot of people
have should I stay in my job that's a
good cushy job or should I uh take this
leap of faith into the unknown give us
like the two-minute story of like you
know how did you think about that and
how did you decide and was that the
right way to think about it yeah I mean
I um like a lot of people had the like
covid moment of what the [__] am I doing
with my life
um and you know am I happy doing it like
you know all of a sudden for the first
time in my life after I guess it had
been six years working in in private
equity which at the time you know it was
like 80 to 100 hour weeks right so you
don't really have time to look up you
don't think about [__] because you're
just working and you're you know you're
making more and more money and so you're
like patting yourself on the back things
are good you're you know you're Indian
Child like Indian mother thinks it
sounds impressive you know things are
good she probably wants you to go get an
MD but it sounds pretty good uh is that
what your mother wanted you to do Sean
uh my mom yeah she was yeah yeah that
all those things she she definitely was
like don't leave a good paying job that
was just like a general rule uh or
general rule of thumb I mean my mom to
this day still asks me why I didn't go
to medical school or why I didn't get a
PhD
in all seriousness like the Indian
mother thing is sort of a meme but it's
also very real the like you know you
should go work for McKinsey if you're
gonna work in uh in Professional
Services that's the only place that is
uh that's respectable
um but yeah man I mean I was doing that
covid hit all of a sudden I was like ah
what am I doing with my life
um had time on my hands to actually like
think about other stuff for the first
time in my professional life and so I
started I mean the Twitter thing I just
like I started writing and I didn't ever
think of it as a potential way to like
go make money or get another job or do
something else but as it started to grow
and as it started to spiral you know we
were in this like group chat together
right and I started seeing friends from
the tech world how they were leveraging
uh you know platforms Twitter Etc to
make money I was like huh I wonder
whether there's a way that I can
actually uh you know build like a little
side hustle with this you know like
whether it was courses or whether it was
an agency business or like whatever it
was I never really thought about the
fund or investing side at the time
um and then candidly like I had a
conversation with you Sean that I
remember being really impactful where I
was like at a real Crossroads and I
thought I was gonna
I thought I was going to kind of just
like go join another type of investing
firm and we were going to move back to
the east coast to be closer family I was
going to do that and I remember you
saying to me like it sounds like you're
just gonna go do the thing that kind of
sounds like it sucks instead of doing
the thing that you actually get a lot of
energy from which is all this new stuff
and that feels scalable and that you're
you know you're fired up about so why
are you making that decision and until
someone just reframed it for me like
that I had never thought about it I was
just gonna type inside continue down the
path that felt safe
um it was like a stupid conversation
frankly but had a pretty big impact you
had described it you were like I'm
thinking about path a or path B but the
way you described it like Pate sounded
like [__] like sounded super hard and
not that much fun and path B sounded
like a lot of fun with just like you
know some unknowns but like definitely
good was gonna come of it and I was like
how is this even a decision like it
sounds like you're saying I'm choosing
between a bad option and a good option
go with the good one funny story about
path a so at the time that path a this
is real was to join like a crossover
hedge fund like a hedge fund one that
also does investments in private tech
companies and my final interview my
final interview I had to pitch a stock
and the stock they gave me to pitch was
Stitch fix and I had to decide like I
had a week and I had to decide whether
it was a buy you know or a short like if
it was a long or a short and I did like
a week of research like made this long
deck like did all this work I mean it
was miserable did all this thing it was
trading at the time at like 46 dollars
and it had come off
um you know it had gone up to like 100
in the whole like arcados you know Bill
Huang was like pumping up stocks but
dude like buying the swaps pumped all
the way up and then it came down to 46
and I pitched it as a buy uh got
rejected because my pitch was shitty and
now that stock is trading at 3.56 so I
would have taken path a and I would have
gotten fired within six months for sure
dude so something that's interesting is
like I get and I know Sean does too I
get asked maybe five times a week if
someone can like write tweets for me or
like cut videos for me and all this
stuff and it's pretty crazy I don't know
if it only happens like what the
popularity level is where you have to
where you start getting those inbounds
but I get it's so often that I get this
and you like it's go there's like this
weird I get people asking me all the
time to go are you in sahil or are you
in this person are you in that person is
sahil friends with this person because
there's this like weird circle jerk of a
Twitter world and it feels feel as
though that like you are connected to
like many many many tens of millions of
followers and reach and like there's
this like weird behind the scenes thing
going on with your agency it's the dark
underground cabal that runs Twitter now
uh no I mean Sean you actually remember
this right didn't like some kid hit you
up and say that he ghost wrote tweets
for me and then you you just texted me
and we're like does this dude ghost
right for you and I was like no I've
never heard of this kid in my life he
was just lying and then I hit him up
saying like yo why are you lying to this
person and he completely panicked
um but yeah man I mean the like the
world of of Ghost writing tweets has now
become again like it's become a meme
because what was it like Business
Insider wrote an article about VCS
getting um getting ghost writers to
write tweets for them that wasn't at all
how my agency thing started it started
um in like late 2020 because I had
started to figure out that threads were
the way that people were growing on
Twitter and keep in mind like you know
Sean you were around the group chat at
the time but that was like before
threads had become the like thread boy
meme that they are today and so there
was like legitimate Arbitrage in writing
quality threads and I had all these
startups that I had invested in the
founders of which were like wow we see a
ton of value in having a platform and a
brand can you help us think through how
to do this because you've done it like I
had at that point got into 75 000
followers or so and so I was like yeah
let me me you know I basically like
started an LLC like an advisory business
basically and I started giving like
strategic support to these startups on
how to think about content and then like
how much would you charge them I was
charging five grand a month
um to a startup for basically like you
know it was like texting and then maybe
like one call every other week and it
was like so low because
um it was so low on time from what they
needed for me because it was mostly like
the founders didn't want to actually
spend a ton of time on it they just
wanted to be able to like kind of
understand it and then they would have
people on their end that just like went
off and did things what was the high
level like one two three bullet points
that you would tell these Founders so
that they could just be better at this
it was basically like you need your two
or three pillars of content that you're
going to be able to talk about
consistently that are like valuable for
you as a startup or as a Founder so if
you're a Founder I mean at the time it
was like if you're a Founder talk about
you know building companies and the
things you're learning along the way
which now is like Ultra saturated on
Twitter right there's like a million
people that aren't necessarily credible
writing about that at the time there
weren't that many Founders doing it like
I don't know if you guys have seen the
like copy AI founder I forget his name
Paul um it might be an investor Sean you
know that business
um
yeah and he was like the first one sort
of that was like really building in
public quote unquote like sharing about
their journey and the things they were
learning so I was basically telling
Founders you have to establish like what
are your two or three pillars that
you're gonna be writing about maybe it's
you know building in public maybe it's
the industry you're in
um you know maybe it's like sharing else
along the way and like vulnerability
because people find that endearing it's
like uh it's called the Pratt fall
effect have you ever heard of that it's
like uh when when people who you
perceive to be perfect show like chinks
in their armor we find it as humans very
endearing and we it actually makes us
like them more and so you're like you
know playing on that you're like sharing
your elves along the way
um but I was basically telling them you
know versions of that on a regular basis
and like helping you know kind of craft
and advise them on the content they were
putting out and it was like five grand a
month
probably had like five or so clients I
think they were all like startups I
either like the founders I knew or I'd
invested in the companies and so I was
kind of around and it was you know
beneficial to me to like see them
continue to grow and do that you like
invest in the companies and they give
you that money right back I like that
yeah it was a good way to hedge them I
mean this was personal Investments at
the time so this was like you know I
might invest like 25k in a company if I
was making that back in five months that
was a pretty good uh cash on cash return
on the original investment
but then like you know like after
um you know the ghost writing thing was
interesting because basically like
early mid-2021 I had a few of those
clients come and say like uh you know
the biggest struggle for us is that we
don't have people that can write this
content like we don't want to build out
a Content team when we're focused on
product and engineering and all that
stuff like do you have people that can
write and right at that time I had done
the course with Julian Shapiro our
friend
um we did a maven course on like how to
build your audience and it was mainly
how to build your audience on Twitter
and so half that course was about like
how to write good threads and how to
write for Twitter and so I had this pool
of like 400 students who had gone
through the course learned the
principles of it knew how to do it that
then I was just able to sort of be a
connector between like freelance you
know writing talent to then support
these startups and you know the the kind
of fundamental of any agency business
for anyone that's starting one is
effectively that you're like creating
price Arbitrage where you're like
charging a client 10 grand for some or
five grand for something that maybe cost
you two and like you know the reality
for most these people is you can pay a
thousand to 2500 bucks a month maybe
depending on the output and you can
easily charge you know a startup or a
brand five for that or you can charge
like a you know a founder or an
entrepreneur who's doing really well and
just made a bunch of money five for just
like the fact that you're the connector
between the two points so that was when
it like I would say like really started
to scale but it was never for VCS for me
like I've never I mean I've never had a
client that was a VC it's it's all been
Founders and it's all been like like
half Tech Founders and half just like
nuts and bolts like meat and potato type
Founders like Sam's guys
[Laughter]
no you're a mean potato guy Sean's my
tech guy you're my meat and potatoes you
know if something's like cool or
interesting then it's kind of more my
thing and if something's like really
boring and like you know generally
correlated with like obesity it's your
thing
so I want to ask you a bunch about like
kind of your your big Vision because
you're going to be president someday I
don't know if people know this there's a
future president sitting with us but
before we do that people always tell us
they're like yo you got to do ideas with
the guests meaning they want to hear
okay you're so hell you see a bunch of
different things you see a bunch of
different worlds what opportunities do
you see that you think some people
somebody should be doing or a cool
startup idea cool business idea a niche
opportunity something maybe you're not
doing or whatever do you have any kind
of ideas on your cheat sheet yeah I've
got three for you guys okay uh let's go
through them so so first on the agency
side just because I think there are two
really obvious ones that like honestly
anyone that's listening could probably
go action on this if they wanted one is
um like LinkedIn growth agency stuff
um massive opportunity here I mean like
you you guys know a couple of our
friends me and a couple of friends are
starting like a spin-off agency that's
just going to focus on LinkedIn because
it's a massive Arbitrage opportunity
right now in audience growth Twitter has
become a lot more saturated because of
the like red boy thing and how many
people are going and doing it LinkedIn
like you I mean you can go post a few
things and immediately be like getting
the 10K plus and for Founders and like
business Builders there's so much
business on those platforms it's huge
for recruiting so basically if you were
to go start this the way I would do it I
would go like go to someone who has a
Twitter presence and you can go create
like Tweet pic uh Pik is the like web
service that I use for it and you can
basically just turn tweets that are like
proven with social proof into these like
carousels on LinkedIn that are the big
growth hack on LinkedIn and if you go do
that for them and just say like look
I'll take over your entire LinkedIn
presence you never have to open LinkedIn
because people hate opening LinkedIn and
you just go and create carousels for
them off of proven tweets and then go
post it for them like two three times a
week off their tweets yeah off their
tweets
um off their tweets or off of like other
writing that exists that they've put out
like say they've written blogs like I
don't know I mean if you went and found
uh you know say it's like Ryan holiday
and he's written a ton of blogs that are
all over the place but doesn't have a
massive LinkedIn presence you can go
like turn his blogs into just shorter
form writing that you put into posts on
LinkedIn and say hey I'll post for you
three times a week you never have to log
in don't even worry about it and we'll
grow you to like 50K by the end of this
year either pay as like you know charge
us like a success fee like if you get to
this level you pay me this or you just
say like pay me five grand a month and
I'll do this for you two and a half
Grand a month and I'll do this for you
and the amount of time it would take you
is literally like I mean you could
probably do like an hour a week to cover
a single person to like you know call it
four hours a month and make five grand
it's like an awesome awesome Arbitrage
opportunity so that's one like any
thoughts on that Sam I I think it's
awesome yeah I've been doing a similar
thing so I hired this guy as a content
remixer for me and um basically it was
take content from the pod or or Twitter
and remix it into content on other
platforms and I focused on link I
focused him on LinkedIn because I
thought thought the thing you just said
I had kind of a hypothesis that that's
true and uh I'm now at 38 000 followers
on LinkedIn and I haven't opened
LinkedIn once so if you see something on
LinkedIn stop me writing it it's me I
mean the same thing happened to me but
it's not me writing that but hold on
Sean so you got 38 000 let's say that
you post by the way this is like in two
months or something like that let's say
you post a product that cost or your
power writing thing let's say it's a
thousand dollars and you sell a thousand
dollar thing to your 38 000 followers
how much revenue will you make from that
I don't know haven't tested it uh sahil
you might know better but I also haven't
been doing it for long enough I wouldn't
expect to be able to get value because I
don't think I've given enough yet like
with Twitter same thing you know like
people see oh man you guys just you can
sell a course you can just like say
you're doing this new thing you get a
bunch of sign ups like yeah but I've
been doing this podcast for three years
do you know 300 episodes you know
hundreds of hours of content that
somebody's listened to so yeah they
trust you and they know they've come to
a decision whether you're smart and
interesting or whether you're full of
[__] and they've you've done they've
made that that they've done all that
work and I've done all that work
beforehand so then would you make an
offer it's just a simple yes or no
um it doesn't fit their life does it
does do they think it'll drive value
they already trust that you could do it
on LinkedIn I wouldn't bet that that
would happen yet because it's just been
so uh recent
yeah I think you have to get I mean
there's like a
there's like a low there's a bar that I
think you have to get over from a
follower account standpoint if you use
that as a proxy before you can like
conceivably Harvest value you gotta like
you know plant enough seeds over a
period of time to Sean's point I think
like 100k is probably the point at which
you can start harvesting value from
LinkedIn Justin Welsh is this guy that
you might have seen on Twitter or
LinkedIn he was like
kind of like Godfather LinkedIn
influencer and I think that dude now is
making like 100k Plus on not even cohort
based courses just like Auto courses
that he generally just promotes through
Linkedin he like he has a newsletter now
that he's built through Linkedin like
built on the back of LinkedIn and now
he's bigger on Twitter because he's
managed to like cross across all of
those but he's doing over 100k a month
in uh in sales revenue on his uh on his
courses which are just like you know
they're just they're they're not cohort
based so he's like putting in no no time
now dude got them stood up this is
interesting Sean have you seen what
sahil's been doing on Instagram
on Instagram now so basically your boy's
blowing up so listen to this so uh
around the same just Dad content no
listen it was just hair it's just mostly
hair and shirts and uh ABS traps but uh
around the same time so saho and I uh
both around the same time we're like all
right let's take Instagram seriously so
I started doing it and I was beating him
nicely adding a thousand people today I
think I started with 5 000 people and I
got to like 48 or 50 000 in a very short
amount of time and he was doing his
thing I was like you need to post twice
a day I think and he starts doing that
and then he just kind of like has
rocketed past me now he's got to 62 000
followers in a very short amount of time
adding one or two thousand people a day
and he's doing this exact same thing
where he's taking his tweets that do
well and just posting them on his
Instagram and like so two points here
one
there's a world where this is just total
vanity nonsense and a complete
distraction from people who have like
their main thing on the other hand what
I'm curious about is how much revenue
can this drive to people if their goal
is not to be a famous person their goal
is just to sell more [__] of whatever
their own they own already and so I'm
curious sahil is have you if kids well
this does this actually drive revenue
for things
other than yeah I mean right now
right now it's generating about a so
Instagram this past month I think
generated a thousand newsletter subs for
me just through the link in my bio
um and that's like you know on average I
probably had 35
000 followers
um during the month and it generated
that many so conceivably as it continues
to scale it'll drive you know well north
of that as it uh as it moves and if you
think a newsletter subscriber form is
worth
you know just off of my sponsor Revenue
probably like three to four dollars per
sub and then if you take into account my
book that's gonna come where it's like
extremely valuable to me if they buy a
book
um I mean it's a bunch of money a month
that's coming off this that scales over
time right and that's just Instagram and
you think about LinkedIn that's another
Big Driver
um you know all these platforms so and
like I mean they're ghost writing
agencies there are people selling
products mostly on Instagram without
ever posting like their face these guys
are literally like making carousels of
images and stuff and they're doing 50 to
100K of Revenue through it
what's an example of that there's this
guy uh Dakota Robertson like wrongs to
write I think it says like Twitter
handle and maybe that's his Instagram
handle too
um and he's got like I don't know 250
000 followers now on on Instagram and
like blew up real fast they're just from
posting his viral tweets over to over to
Instagram like almost never shows his
face
um and dude has a thriving ghost riding
business through this gotcha I'm torn
because on one hand uh you are like
perfect execution of a strategy that I
now hate and so I'm like respect to you
but I'm like I don't even want to talk
about this because I know what's gonna
happen is there's now gonna be 9 000 new
people who go this podcast gonna breed
nine thousand new people that are gonna
go be like this is my thing I'm gonna do
this he said I can make you know x
amount of money per month and their
execution is going to be nowhere near
yours
um and in general this is like a it's
like a pathway that definitely works but
it's like um like the soul sucking yeah
it's like it's like getting closing and
it provides activity is closing that's
an important Point yeah I do think like
look I mean when I started writing the
threads I mean Sean you were the same
way right like any thread you wrote
would blow the hell up early on because
there just weren't that many of them and
so it was like it's a market it wasn't
saturated now it's pretty hard to get a
thread to like really take off unless
you're doing the like 10 YouTube
channels that will change your life for
free which is the things that it's like
getting fit through Power walking is
power walking gonna burn calories yeah
yeah for sure are you probably not going
to get injuries yeah but like you have
to look like a doofus doing it in the
process everyone in the neighborhood's
gonna know you is that weirdo power
walking like you know what I mean and
I'm guilty of this too right like I did
this strategy as well of being like Oh
I'm gonna create content for for you
know for fun initially this podcast
Twitter that sort of thing and then oh
[__]
okay if I kind of sell five percent of
my soul or ten percent of my soul to the
algorithm I think I can get this bigger
okay I started doing that and then it's
like oh I can make good money doing this
and I you know make some money doing
that and that feels fun but like
I just want to say as a public service
announcer there's some people who are
going to go do this but let's say you're
somebody who's awesome I'm just gonna
say this now
this was awesome to do when it wasn't
figured out now that it's figured out
this is a certified official small boy
stuff and I do not recommend this to
anybody else uh and I myself have
stopped doing this too I haven't posted
a threat and but if you are interested
in this laid-back [__] style
is perfect execute that's the difference
though anything like I I've I'm sitting
in this house because of it I I tweeted
this as a lovely house I got a lovely
house I go I write no I mean look you do
you you have to figure out what the what
the area is where you're gonna do it
that's not crazy saturated and cringe
and and to your point like you got to
figure out what percent cringe are you
willing to be like if writing a thread
is 10 cringe like what level above that
just natural Baseline when are you gonna
figure that out are you talking me
what I'm willing to accept that
um already like 10 of people just
immediately see it and they're like oh
this is super cringe and then you just
have to decide like what level you're
willing to go above that if 100 is like
10 Chrome extensions that'll change your
life and 50 is like uh you know here
like the TED Talks that change my life
what's like 20 is it some of the stuff I
post probably and like if that helps a
few people out there and like a bunch of
people get pissed and think that it's
not for them I don't really give a [__]
personally like if I help one person and
you know someone hits me up and says
like hey that changed my perspective on
X Y or Z that's what garyvee's been
doing for decades man that guy's a
legend of putting out content that's
like listicles and like you know like
motivational stuff Tony Robbins like
Grant Cardone these guys like they get
hate because it freaking works and it
helps people right so I don't know the
thing I would say like have you ever
been to a Tony Robbins event yeah and uh
I'm sure if you went to like you went to
what like at least the power within or
something yeah great I went to loved it
thought it was amazing I don't know if
you liked it you could give it a quick
reaction but I have a different point
yeah
um I love it I mean I love Tony Robbins
stuff me too and he gets on stage and
he's doing all the things that you could
Chris besides somebody for he's he's
clapping he's saying get up and jump
he's saying when I say uh you know he's
going to ask a very basic question and
the only answer is yes but the whole
crowd says yes like a cult and you're
like oh he's doing all the things but
he's doing it at like an A plus plus
level he totally probably in my opinion
the best public speaker I've ever seen
uh and I've seen a lot I'm still like
Obama yeah yeah he he is he I think he's
even more powerful than Obama because
Obama is smooth but Obama doesn't get
people Tony Robbins to get you to walk
across coals and like shout your
greatest fear out loud I've never seen
Obama control a crowd for 12 straight
hours like Tony Robbins will do in an
event but here's what happens you look
around in the crowd and you're like
there's a whole spectrum of people at
the one I was in it was like there were
celebrities there you know the the guy
from 300 what's his name Gerald Butler
he was there he was like right two rows
down from me I was like wow this is
interesting there's some interesting
people here and then in the hallways I
would meet a bunch of people that
thought they were the next Tony Robbins
and they were life coaches and
motivational speakers and and they were
you know change consultants and every
cringed name you could think of and then
you go look at their stuff and it's the
same concept but not executed at that
level because they didn't have the hard
one life experiences that that guy had
to actually like create this content
they didn't have 40 Years of sharpening
their craft and becoming the best they
didn't have the natural talents and
Charisma and you know Larger than Life
presence and so you can you can look at
the best you can look at the garyvee's
in the Tony Robbins you can look at you
on Twitter and say that's dope you know
I could do that and some people a very
small amount of people can do that but
for most people they will fall into the
pit of cringe because they're not going
to execute it at that same level they
didn't have those hard-won lessons of
actually knowing what they're talking
about and uh and they're going to end up
in this like weird middle ground and uh
I think that's the scary part
I can find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling database
HubSpot grow better
I mean that's kind of like um that's
like any Market though right like you
know someone starts a company and it's
the a plus version of some like a
restaurant chain someone starts a
restaurant chain it's like the a plus of
that thing and then a bunch of people
come in to try to mimic it and it's like
the b-plus version and you know like
whatever like say in and out is the A
Plus Burger version and someone tries to
come in and start the like five guys or
whatever next I'm probably gonna get
hate for saying in and outs better than
five guys but you know whatever like you
kind of have the diluted versions and
the question is like hey do you care
that you're the deluded version of Tony
Robbins if you're making money doing it
and taking care of your family because
like I know a lot of people that are
just like I don't give a [__] like you
know I grew my audience super cringe
stuff and I'm making 25 Grand a month I
was making five doing my prior job or
ten doing my prior job I'm making this
sitting at home and I get spend time
with my kids what do I give a [__] if a
bunch of tech people think that I'm
cringe like I'm making money it is what
it is and so I kind of I appreciate that
too the other thing I would say is like
what game are you playing like what is
the long-term game you're playing and
for me I was always thinking about like
what is the thing I'm trying to build
long term like I wasn't trying to be you
know a Twitter thread like a thread guy
like that's not my long-term vision of
what it was it vaulted me from being a
nobody private Equity guy as you said to
like I signed a book deal last month
like a big book deal last month you know
like I raised a fund I never would have
been able to raise a fund as like this
nobody VP in private equity and so to me
it's like what are you actually
parlaying that [__] into as you continue
to go if you're able to find the thing
that you think you're a plus at even if
it's for a short period of time like how
are you using that to Vault yourself
into that next level where you're like
I'm not even in the same class as these
other guys that are doing the thing I
was doing previously because I moved
into whatever that next you know that
like upper echelon is dude are you
worried about uh Elon screwing it up for
you
not really you know what's funny well
did you see what he really quick he he
like said something and then Steph my
old co-worker said like does this mean
that like the thread boys are gonna go
away and actually forget his reply what
did he say but it sounded like he was
saying you did like a crying Emoji I
mean yeah like I think it was something
about he said um you know you could
basically like put a long form text onto
a tweet so you don't have to like people
were used to take a screenshot of like
their Notes app on their phone to post a
long form thing I think all that stuff
is good I mean like look I've already
benefited from being early to a market
like I grew to a big level I built a
brand that now extended into things that
I own like the newsletter you know
that's gotten quite large and it's
growing faster like the funder like the
book whatever it is
um I would be more worried if I was like
just starting out in any one of these
things and like had dedicated all this
time you know if you've rewound me a
year and I was like just starting to get
all these things going I'd probably be a
little more worried
um but the reality is it's like eat or
be eaten man if you're if you're not
like figuring out the new way to to uh
you know be on the front of something
and be building in these other areas
um you're in for a tough time no matter
what let's talk about this newsletter
thing
um so this is the second idea
um
biggest issue I have with my newsletter
is
I want to write it like I love writing
that's my number one thing that gives me
a lot of energy I freaking hate thinking
about and dealing with any of the like
business or growth side of the
newsletter the business side is very
easy to Outsource there's like I mean
you know there's there's ad agencies now
convertkit has an ad Network where
they'll manage the whole back end of
your newsletter they'll bring in
sponsors for it they'll send you the
money it's like super super easy it's
amazing Nathan crushed it getting that
thing out there but the like growth side
of newsletters is completely untouched
there's no one out there that I've been
able to find that is like a full sweet
growth service for your newsletter and
when I say growth Suite I literally mean
like I want someone thinking about my
landing pages and optimizing that I want
someone thinking about referral networks
newsletter swaps I want someone thinking
about paid ads you know SEO for my
website to drive Subs how to optimize it
across my different social channels
literally just someone that's sitting
around thinking about growth for the
newsletter so that I can just focus on
writing and I'd literally be willing to
pay I mean my willingness to pay at the
size of newsletter that I'm at now and
given what newsletter Subs are worth to
me is very high like I would easily pay
10 grand a month to someone that could
figure that out and do it in one place
on top of whatever I would spend on paid
ads Etc do you think that that thing
work week is going to do that uh no dude
I mean like uh I don't know how much you
guys know about where I don't know a
whole ton about work week but from what
I can tell it's mostly the like back-end
Services of news letters and there's
another one called Smooth Ops that I
think spun out from morning Brew didn't
work week spun out of the hustle didn't
it not spun out they uh they worked for
the guy was there yeah same thing with
the morning Brew um smooth Ops like my
understanding of all those is that
they're much more focused on like
helping you monetize and um you know
managing your like business that you can
focus on writing I literally just want
someone that just all they think about
all day like a an absolute killer that's
just all they think about is growth I
mean Sean did you have someone I mean or
was Ben like that at milk Road my guy
was right Sean no
Ben Ben was the guy he woke up every day
and just said how do we get more
subscribers and like you know that's
that was his mission and that's what he
did so uh you know that's the but you
know we needed it's like if you don't
have a that was like more of a company
uh whereas like you know most people's
personal things are not like you're at a
size where there's just not that many
newsletters that are at your size
um that can afford to pay for something
like that
um you know how many people how many
people could afford to pay 10K per month
to try to drive growth so I think a lot
so my hypothesis is so I tweeted this
um and a bunch of people were like
replying saying they would pay for it in
different ways my hypothesis is that
there's a ton of like successful
Founders and entrepreneurs that want to
build a newsletter an owned list or like
an essay type thing like what Sam Altman
or Paul Graham have where they have you
know SEO and newsletter you know like
emails that are coming to them and
they're willing to pay a lot because
they actually have been successful and
just have a bunch of money they don't
need it to be Revenue generating out at
the outset
um and I think you I mean I bet if you
developed some sort of core competency
and basically like partner say someone
partnered with me and proved it out over
like two three months hey it drove this
and then were able to use me as a case
study maybe I own a percentage of it you
know on the upside and so I'm incented
to like bring them new referrals I bet
you could grow a pretty big business
there quickly yeah you only need like 20
clients basically to make this like you
know worth your while yeah I mean if
it's a personal business you don't even
need 20 clients I mean you can get 10 at
five a month or 10 at 10 a month and you
have like you know it's 80 80 plus
percent margin probably business if you
just find it simple but are you having
the headache of having a service
business yeah I mean yeah it's
definitely not products like I've
thought about starting an agency like
maybe 20 times my life and then
literally five minutes later every
single time I'm like
don't go in the service business don't
go in the service business now I
we have several friends that have done
it right like you know Andrew Wilkinson
did it with meta lab our buddy Greg has
done a great job with it with late
checkout you're doing it now with your
thing so you know maybe I have the wrong
bias here what do you think I mean what
you have to do is hire a great operator
if you want to be the like owner of some
percentage of it and not have the
headaches you got to just recruit a
killer operator who's gonna run all of
it I mean that's what we're doing with
the spin out agency that we're doing now
around LinkedIn stuff is like just gonna
hire someone exceptional and give them
like 15 of the ups and just say like
you're a hustler you're a killer you can
get a whole ton man that's my finance
teams man really that's the that's the
uh that's the no-name PE guy coming out
of me right there
um I thought earlier guy was a guy who
likes you know dodgeball and recess like
that's what PE is to me
earlier he was talking about Beta And I
was like you're talking about nerds I
don't understand what the [__] what the
hell is beta it is a good thing yeah
it's like a good thing I was like I
don't understand what that means you're
kind of a low beta guy actually Sam if I
think about it like you kind of you're
kind of like even key like I feel like I
know within a band what I'm gonna get
out of you any any given day I I think
you're complimenting me but I don't
understand I I you know you like you
show up you tweeted about that recently
you hate when people say they're gonna
do something and then not do it like you
so you take pride in being low beta like
people know what they can expect from
you on a given day by the way what a
what a stupid thing to tweet yeah like I
like long walks in the beach and movies
like who who likes somebody who says
they're gonna do something and doesn't
do it what an obvious tweet yeah first
of all give me the clout that I deserve
like don't hate when it's Silo say don't
hate number two I'm not saying it's like
people who say they're afraid of heights
like yeah everyone's afraid of heights
but like you just like some people that
just like I you know it's like what's
high on your list I don't think that uh
I don't know like like there's a lot of
things that annoy you Sean that that
don't annoy me and vice versa like
what's one thing that annoys you Sean
that you don't make a noise Sam I don't
think anything annoys him nothing annoys
me
that's the beauty of it wait really you
don't think anything bothers you no I
think yeah now I want to dig it bothers
you I uh I guess what bothers me is only
usually things with myself so like if I
find myself in a bad mood or like
getting annoyed with something or
getting bothered by something or getting
impatient with something that's actually
the thing that bothers me I'm like oh
man I let this get to me like for like
that second that's the thing that gets
to me right so usually it's not
something that frustrates me or annoys
me it's usually either impatient or
boredom or
um feeling cranky or tired or something
like that you know like and I'm like oh
no I I don't want to be that way that
that bothers me so for years I used to
say that Sean I was like I was like I
think I'm gonna have a pretty steady
path to wealth creation and Sean you
either gonna like it's not gonna be as
extreme I think we joked around with
Minister B's for like you know six out
of ten times if you were reborn you
would be a degenerate like Gambler or
drug addict and like four four out of
ten times you'd be successful with Sean
it's not that bad but it's like you know
you're gonna you're the type of guy who
can rolls the dice and like you might
actually hit it big there's a good
chance or you might like just be only
okay for a long time and now uh so I was
basically saying yeah your likelihood I
think of being a billionaire is actually
higher than mine
um but your likelihood of being like a
degenerate is probably also higher yeah
High beta yeah but here's the problem
with Sean I've just realized over the
past handful of months he is too
emotionally healthy to probably be
incredibly successful he has this
problem that few people have which is
he's just happy you know what I mean
he's got this it's just this it depends
on your definition of success man I
would argue that Sean is the most
successful then man if he's like super
happy yeah you need to find sex by
success by these superficial things like
happiness and well-being and all that
[__] stupid stuff yeah I do I will
say that Sean has had more like high
highs and low lows this year at least
for my like perceived view but it's not
our group text and like and he's totally
unfazed like Sean I mean look flashback
to like you know a like crypto crash
right I'm like yo Sean's down bad I'm
texting Sam I'm like is Shawn okay like
Sean's texting the group chat totally
fine I'm like yo Sean broke like is Sean
doing margin called right now like I
have no idea what's going on and then
Sean's like yo I sold all my stock and I
was like holy [__] Sean sold the bottom
Sean sold the bottom like Mark it's
roaring in June and then the market
crashes again and Sean's a genius
traitor that like sold the top of the
market or something this dude is just
like does that stuff bother you at all
Sean like first of all what person uh
prior to selling a business recently but
what uh was your Network down just a
significant amount yeah probably I mean
it's hard to calculate that sort of
thing so but let's say liquid of the
liquid stuff so I'm not counting equity
in companies uh you know it's probably
down 50 or something like that I mean
most of the Investments I I didn't keep
much cash this is my investment strategy
pre-2022 right so my best value is
pre-22 was Cash is trash and you know
fist bumps all around to my boys who
thought the cash was trash then
um
oh dude is there a safer investment than
Amazon this blue chipper right like
that's my version of of safety is yeah
I'm gonna put in some boring tech
companies you know the Amazons Googles
Facebooks of the world what could go
wrong and um and then lastly you know
then you know a huge amount of startups
that were uh that were you know getting
marked up like crazy fist bumps all
around getting my UPS because my UPS was
going ups and then the last thing was
crypto and I was like oh well see your
boy's a genius and moved a huge
percentage of his net net worth into you
know Bitcoin and ethereum and um oh and
then this Luna [__] that's popping I'm
doing great so you know that's that was
me before so basically every single
thing I had invested in has gone you
know what's my you know that was that
thing like my terrible horrible no good
very bad day like I was basically having
that for this year in terms of
Investments but
you know whatever did it bother you well
I mean I like losing money but like you
know did I let it bother me no like you
know I basically steps no I took steps I
was like okay well what matters here
like okay let me just first get
perspective uh you know am I in any kind
of hardship is my family doing poor no
they're they're fine right secondly what
should I actually do do I need to make
some adjustments was I wrong about
certain things or should I do some
things to give myself more comfort so
why did I sell I sold I basically margin
called myself I was like you know what I
think things are gonna go lower and I
don't want to sweat this all the time so
I'm gonna sell this amount here so that
I don't have to worry about anything I'm
gonna move more into cash and I'm gonna
book this loss because I think that'll
that'll offset against some gains that I
have this year and um you know then I
won't have to think about this stuff for
a little while I'll focus on these other
things that I want to be focusing on
because I'm not a Trader I'm not a like
investment genius so that's not going to
be my goal and then um yeah it'll just I
don't know that I I never got my
happiness from when it was going up so
why would I get my sadness from when
it's going down didn't make sense to me
you must have felt good when Luna like I
think you you originally plugged Luna in
milk Road at like 40. and I like I
bought some I was like yo Sean's pretty
smart he knows this crypto [__] hands
down and so I like I bought a bag like I
you know I'm not like I'm not really a
degenerate crypto guy but I like bought
a bag of Luna and that [__] went up to
like 118 and I was like yo Sean is my
God like uh Sean what other what other
ideas do you have and then I we were
supposed to interview on our old pod we
were supposed to interview dokon like I
had hit him up on Twitter he's supposed
to come on the pod on like a Thursday
and on that Sunday like Luna had been
wavering like it had come down to like
80 or something and I get an email from
his assistant that just says uh
unfortunately uh doe will have to
reschedule the interview for this
Thursday and I'm sitting in bed and I'm
like I got a little bit of the
heebie-jeebies like I don't know what
this is so I go downstairs and I sell my
entire bag at like I don't know a small
gain like not not good I sell the whole
thing next morning I wake up and that
shit's at like five like the whole the
whole thing unraveled overnight and then
I get an email from his assistant saying
like he's going to have to cancel the
interview and I'm like yeah well this
dude has a red notice out for him no
[__] he's not coming on our podcast at
this point yeah that was that was a bad
day I was on vacation I was in Hawaii
with my family and I'm watching my time
and I'm like I don't even have I'm not
even at my computer like I can't even
get to my crypto like it's not like on
my laptop or whatever so I'm like well
couldn't couldn't make a move if I
wanted to uh so I guess I'll just like
you know lose all this money here and uh
you know just enjoy this vacation
there's nothing else I could do at this
point you were remarkably cool about it
I remember texting with you that day the
um the framework you've talked about in
the past that I love around this stuff
is your um local versus tourist thing I
think that's so good of like you know uh
tourists like freak out when the seasons
change and Just Bounce yeah and locals
are aware that there are seasons and
that you know it comes in swings and
they're aware of the environment so they
can stick it out and be fine through it
I've always just thought there's a third
one which is the like stubborn and local
like the dude that lives in the Coastal
Village and is like ah Global warming's
not real and then he's [__]
underwater and like drowning and he's
like ah Global warming's not real as he
drowns and so I'm always just like how
do you make sure that you don't go from
being the like the local and you're
proud of being a local to the stubborn
local that just sits there until you die
yeah that's the hardest thing and I
remember with startups this was always
the question because you'll hear a story
like Pinterest had no traction for over
a year and then finally started to work
because he walked into an Apple store
and like started putting Pinterest as a
default homepage on these you know he
hustled he was determined and it's like
oh okay got it so determination just
keep going even when all the data's
telling you that this ain't working
and then there's like the exact other
advice which is like yo you got to be
super data driven feedback oriented you
got to listen to the market all that
matters is are you making something
people want and if you have no users you
got to like you know make adjustments
you got to Pivot and so the hardest
question as a Founder is to know
am I being the right kind of stubborn
right so am I being stubborn because I'm
right and I need to you know just tweak
just make small adjustments and just
stay at it be determined and be
persistent or am I banging my head
against the wall and I need to listen to
the to the signals and I need to be
changing my mind and nobody can give the
generic advice about when to do what
it's super it's like super context
dependent super circumstance dependent
same thing with investing right like you
know am I should I should I should I
still believe in something even you know
do I believe in Facebook stock now that
it's getting crushed right and for me I
went and bought more recently because I
was like
uh you know what do I believe about this
company and has that changed so the
tourist first local right is you got to
ask yourself like does the thing I
believed about this has that changed do
I have new information that makes me
update my thinking here
um do I am I you know am I holding on to
this position just so that I don't feel
like I'm wrong right like you know am I
am I willing to upset except being wrong
you gotta ask yourself all these
questions and be able to be honest with
yourself and that changed uh with crypto
has what sorry has your opinion of
crypto changed and your conviction
um no my my opinions my conviction has
stayed the same but that's about crypto
as a whole right then on each specific
maybe project or coin you might have
like a slightly different opinion you
know well what's what's one thing that
you think is [__] now that you
didn't think was [__] a year and a
half ago so I'll give you an example
where that's not true then I'll give an
example where that's true so the not
true one is like let's take Luda for
example the the bet on Luna was always
knowing that there's this the way it was
architect it was this thing is gonna
rock it up because the sort of the what
they call the ponza economics right like
the game theory incentive uh yeah but
people don't understand like basically
it's just like economic a series of
economic incentives and so the
incentives were were aligned such that
this thing should go up during the
during you know when as certain
participants behave a certain way and
from the beginning there was always
these blog posts out there about what
does the death cycle look like so what
if this reversed course would this not
because Luna's the collateral would it
not cause it to you know collapse really
fast and the question was like will that
happen won't that happen so even when
you invested at the beginning we wrote
Our Little investment memo to ourselves
about like here's our one pager why we
think this is a good idea and why we
think this could go horribly wrong when
it crashed it wasn't like something we
never had never thought of it was oh
yeah that downside scenario we talked
about that's exactly what happened right
like basically there was a giant you
know cell pressure that CR that caused
that cascading down cycle yep that we
always thought that could happen we had
hoped it wouldn't happen we had thought
that maybe there was a you know there
would be a way to to put by pressure
back against it but nope it wasn't going
to work and so this is very fast example
of basically
just because it turned out bad doesn't
mean that the
um doesn't mean I changed my position
because actually at the beginning we
said well here's why I'm not putting my
entire net worth into this right I put
250k into it that's not like a a massive
bet for me uh it's a solid-sized bet
right so it's like you know I put an
appropriately sized bet because I
thought it had upside and I thought
there was some some key risks with it
the thing that I would say I've changed
my opinion most on is I thought
man if people start to worry about
inflation and they look at man you know
I have the same 100K in my bank but it
just doesn't buy me the same amount it
used to right they'll realize like
people will become more aware that the
money they have is diminishing the cash
they have the US dollars they have is
diminishing in value that they will
probably look to go to a monetary system
that doesn't have that problem
and so the idea that Bitcoin will do
well if people start to if if inflation
becomes something that people are more
and more worried about with the US
dollar
and that hasn't happened inflation got
as bad as it's ever been but people's
response was more conservative than
aggressive people did not make a change
to the Bitcoin monetary system which
would not have that problem
um they sort of you know sort of stuck
with it and actually the US Dollars
gained strength because other currencies
got crushed even worse and so the
dollars gained strength so that was one
that I had thought that this was this is
what would happen it makes me reassess
was my logic incorrect or um or
something else you know what what did I
get wrong about this idea that in a high
inflation environment Bitcoin should be
something that people start moving more
into I mean the Bitcoin one is actually
pretty interesting Sean because I've
thought about that a lot too of is there
is there something just like
in the segmentation of how the price
went up that is impacting that because I
still think
basically my assumption of why that
didn't happen like why that you know
scenario of high inflation and people
flood into this is that most of the
price increase was actually just driven
by this like number go up you know crazy
uh you know loose monetary policy people
just pump into speculative you know high
risk assets and that it wasn't really
driven by like Believers like you who
underlying were like oh there's really
good fundamentals the technology really
makes sense driving it up it was mostly
just like my random friends who were
like haha Bitcoin number go up this is
great and then they freaked out when it
went the other direction and pulled out
you know interest rates rise and you
pull out I wonder whether like if you
segmented it somehow of like the true
underlying technology Believers my guess
would be that the picture would look
different like people that really are
like thinking about the technology and
thinking about the underlying
um you know kind of like monetary policy
that exists on the network my guess
would be those people think that this is
a great time to be accumulating and
buying yeah I think you're right um I
think you're right but basically it's
just in my mind it was like a very
simple picture it was like you're
playing one game and the rules of this
game are that the bank gives you some
money it's my game of Monopoly where the
bank gives you some money but every year
your money becomes worth a little bit
less by Design they're trying to make a
two or three percent worse per year but
sometimes if it gets 10 worse per year
right or nine percent worse per year
right that's the the game is is set up
that way and hey oh yo there's this
other new edition of Monopoly that came
out or that doesn't happen to your money
my assumption was like oh people will
just start to move to the new edition
because they're not gonna like when
their money becomes less valuable over
time uh but I I don't think that's the
message that's gone across it was
basically bitcoin's how you get rich or
Bitcoins how you lose your money and
that's the narrative that actually like
played out uh because it was more it was
more aggressive but uh Bitcoin will make
you rich was it easier sell to people
yeah and it was also the reason why
they'll start to sell their Bitcoin when
they real when they feel like oh
bitcoin's crashing by the way I've got
one more non-agency business idea for
you what is non-services maybe it's
slightly certain not that much Services
more product uh mobile podcast and video
Studio yeah man dude it's such a pain in
the butt dude huge pain in the ass buy
like a few vans
get them out with like a pretty fire
setup just in the back of like a normal
sized band doesn't even have to be an RV
for like two to three people could fit
deck it out with like a few good DSLR
cameras that can do the recording like
dual camera setups that you have like a
few mics hanging off the sides and
basically go and post it up in a couple
of major cities like one band in each
major city it has like dope backgrounds
cool lighting like you know whatever do
the neon signs and [__] in there and
rent it out for like 500 bucks for two
hours to do podcast recordings or like
you know a couple hundred bucks to do
like people going in and filming
Instagram shorts tick tocks [__] like
that like if you put one in LA and you
put one in New York City I bet you could
kill it on a cash on cash return on one
of those I just joined this gym called
the collective in Austin and it's like
this like fancy whatever like and
everyone there looks like an Instagram
model and they have uh like co-working
there as well but they also have three
Studios for podcast and picture taking
like they just they just really don't
know their audience and I went there and
everyone looks like they're the type of
person who is like if you follow a
shirtless rip guy on uh Instagram and
they live in Austin they're probably a
member here and I mean if you catch them
on bad lighting they don't even look
that good but like somehow in that
lighting you'd look unreal
I I I I think you're making fun of me uh
I don't know I think makes a huge
difference with uh with these like
Instagram models right so like you just
get good Lighting on one of those things
I bet you could wait I do think these
like mobile Studio though you could
crush it let me ask you I'm looking at
these uh U-Haul box trucks so how much
do these cost to buy so it looks like
you could buy a used one of these for
like 25 Grand right so 25 Grand and
let's say and you only have to put five
down yeah you put five down you're
probably gonna need to put another five
into the kit like to make the the thing
work uh and you probably need to do
operating the thing but maybe maybe you
could get rid of that probably not you
probably have to have an operator on
site so I think that's the that's the
tricky part where you got to sell it as
a membership basically it's got to be a
gym membership uh so it's like you could
use this studio you could just book it
when it's free
um but you got to be like a monthly
member if you're you know if you're
doing 500 a month or whatever and you
have a studio on demand that's a genius
idea to do it as a membership actually
because dude the thing that made me
think of this is like in New York now
there's these couple of Studios where
people are doing all like in-person
podcasts like there's this like what the
[__] media is one of them yeah I go to a
stream and they're like they're solid
they're not great but they're having to
pay New York City rent to like to do
this and so I can't imagine the
economics are that great if you got a
truck and you just bought it you could
go post this thing up in a parking lot
and every two two hours just moved to a
different parking lot and like you never
have to pay rent you're paying the you
know like carrying cost of the of the
truck and you're paying the whatever
five to ten Grand it takes you to
actually we're gonna get the truck we're
gonna call it mudio the mobile Studio
mudio the mudio boys we might get a
branding agency to work on the name but
yeah wait let me ask you something
deafening silence as feedback on your
name
but it's not let me ask you a question
so Sean and I are trying to get popular
on YouTube right now with this with this
thing and one thing that's kind of the
elephant in the room when everyone talks
to you I mean I know Sean talks about
this constantly is that you are just
ridiculously good looking
do you think that this shtick of yours
of having good hair and being good
looking is is that image working for you
and what aesthetic shtick should Sean
and I have
first off calling it a shtick is pretty
hilarious to me um you know this chick
you have it's like oh my face thing yeah
yeah like let's talk about it the
platforms that are visual it obviously
helps to like when people are scrolling
through things for like people to stop
and say oh the person is like attractive
right like it just when you're scrolling
can you see an attractive girl you're
saying you're hot it helps
us you agree was that a Mean Girls
I'm a millennial through and through
the fact that I knew that it was a Mean
Girls reference is just as telling you
are a big girl
um no look I mean for you guys uh you're
both good looking dudes am I gonna sell
you short Sam you've got like a little
look with the like fake glasses I don't
think those have a prescription on them
they're definitely fake dude and then
and then Sean Sean's got the like you
know my favorite line that Sean ever had
is uh you know if you're not gonna be
good looking be interesting looking and
I tell that to like everyone that I give
advice to it Sean's not interesting
looking man look at this beard he's got
the salt dude
like he looks like literally every
single person who shops at like a
generic grocery store in the suburbs
what's wrong with us that's a
little bit of a Vibe but that's not
interesting I don't know man I mean I
think you guys can play up the whole
like your stick of these two guys that
look completely different that are like
somehow friends like you guys are like
cat dog man you remember that show back
in the day we're going for it we're
going for like why are these guys famous
that's what we need to do if we just get
over the hump so it's possible like this
these guys that there's nothing special
about them but that's our thing though
that there's nothing special I don't
think you have to be that good looking
on YouTube by the way like you guys
don't need to be like models on YouTube
um if you like look at the people that
have crushed on YouTube it's not like
hot dudes and hot chicks on YouTube
necessarily not that you guys aren't hot
I don't want you to come away I don't
want Sam to text me later being like hey
man what you said
because I know I'm gonna get that text
later tonight from Sam wait but you're
wrong hot dudes do better on YouTube I
don't think they do better I don't think
that's right I mean I'm not on YouTube
yet I'm gonna get on YouTube here soon
and I'll let you know whether we think
that's true so you're saying you think
you're hot yeah you got this real burden
you're carrying my friend
well like Alex hermosi's got the thing
where he wears like those stupid cut off
jeans now and and he's just like yoked
that nose nose strip and like the No
Strings level of of being being muscular
that's perfect example of you don't have
to be great looking you got to be
interesting looking yeah dude he's
peacock and hardcore and it's kind of
just a look it's a look man and like
each of you guys has a look and if you
can just stick to a consistent look it's
like Chris Saka with his Cowboy shirts
like you need your thing yeah I've been
actually I've been thinking about this
for a long time I've been needing a
uniform I tweeted this out I go I'm
looking for a uniform I want to look the
same every time I'm on this podcast so I
need something that from here up like a
robe It's gotta be yeah maybe a robe
It's gotta be signature and um I'm in
the market so I'm taking suggestions I'm
gonna put a bounty on this actually I'm
gonna give a thousand dollar bounty to
anybody who can help me develop my the
chest up look
that's what I'm looking at
I kind of want to see you do like a
traditional Indian attire for it like it
could be kind of fire if you were
wearing like a dope like kurta or like
you know some sort of like Indian you
know up top I think that'd be kind of
fire Sean Puri it could be part of your
whole like angle with the name and stuff
that's true okay you're eligible for the
Bounty right now I might I might throw
into it I also might match it just
because I think it's gonna be funny to
see you heard it here
I'll throw in a thousand I'll throw in a
thousand on top of it issues before he's
on the hook for a thousand yeah no I'm
not I don't I don't give it a peer
pressure
this is the stupidest thing ever I'm not
gonna give someone a thousand dollars
they can still tell Sean what t-shirt to
wear
you have a signature look already so
it's easier for you to say yeah kind of
like no you've got like a little like
the pretty boy thing going with the like
non-prescription
not a grandfather type of thing yeah
it's good yeah you are gonna be like
you're gonna be a quintessential father
you're gonna have a lot of stern talks
with your child I already know it's
coming uh I don't know what to say to
this thank you yeah yeah I want to hear
this before you go what is the grand
plan what is the Grand Vision for
yourself so you went from No Name PE guy
that as we established to to Legendary
thread boy to uh now CNBC contributor
book deal guy author I think you're
gonna be president is that I I joke
about that a lot but I I genuinely
believe you could become the president
someday if you wanted to do you have a
grand plan for yourself what's the
vision I could see that being in the
cards long term running for public
office I don't know if president is a
role that you necessarily want I think
it's like probably one of the hardest
and worst jobs in the world you guys go
in like Obama went in looking young and
then he you know leaves all gray like
looking you know looking rough it's like
the highest stress job in the world
running for governor would be I don't
know that could be pretty funny to be a
governor of a state do you know anything
about politics I've never known you to
be studied public policy I did I did my
Master's in public policy dude oh yeah
so that was always like what I wanted to
do I mean I took a class on basket
weaving like that doesn't like what like
you know do you think the people that
are serving in public office today know
a lot about politics it's like what is
it's sort of like the naval thing of
like you don't read a business book to
no business like there's no such thing
as politics it's like you know are you a
reasonable thinker do you have the
ability to change your mind which right
now politicians do not and can you
inspire people do you would you get
people to move on things which party
would you be I don't even know I'm an
independent man so I mean I've I've
voted Democrat I voted Republican in
Prior election so I actually I actually
don't know what party I probably I'm
hoping that a third party Rises over the
next 20 years before I actually go do
this because I hate the direction that
you know like polar politics has gone
um you know it's just like the loudest
minority on each side I could see you
being a good politician because you
pretty much never take a stand on
anything kind of like what you just did
you're like I I always call it I'm like
you're a PC like the rock man you never
say anything inappropriate like you you
you you you are like like the rock
well yes but he never takes a stand on
anything he's always he Hedges
everything he says you you could be
beautiful for a politician all right
well I'm counting on your fundraising
for support Tim
I'll even introduce you as my hot friend
Sam when you come up to the speech at my
uh at my future thank you you're already
doing it for me then you're already
lying you're already lying we got good
politician uh well thanks for coming on
where what do you want to do you want to
promote something is that a thing do you
have something to promote I don't know
man people kind of know where to find me
I'm at Tahoe Bloom on every everything
and my newsletter is at my website
sohoboom.com well I'm happy we finally
got you on uh we'll have to do it again
we're gonna get another I'm gonna ask
Austin Reef to come on that'll be
another group chat guy we've asked
Nikita to come on a few times but he's
you know weird the key just he's busy
right now yeah like basking in the glory
of his gas app thing no he's just thinks
it's cool to tell me no I think
they're coming Nikita Nikita right now
like Nikita's been that guy that's like
oh my God guys I hate running this app
this is so tough and then like you'll
see like on his Instagram him like
having a photo shoot at his house like
posing out like looking like this like
his girlfriend the behind the scenes
says oh my God this looks like an album
cover
Nikita's living his best life man more
props to him because that dude had
called his shot and has actually gone
and done it so we'll get him on it we'll
get Austin on we got to get a few more
we've had Huber on but uh dude thanks
for coming and doing this we appreciate
it thank you guys
foreign
[Music]